(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] It's like
y'all called each other
to match, like today.
- That's it.
The Scots amongst this.
- Yes. Yes.
- The Scot is rubbing
off on you like at home.
Yes. You are amazingly beautiful pregnant.
That does not happen for all of us.
(everyone chuckles)
That is amazing.
Which baby is this? Baby number...
- Three.
- Three, right?
- And done. I told the doctor.
I was like, take everything
out that you need to take out.
- Yeah.
- So.
(audience chuckles)
- I said that on my second one
and then she said, did she tell you?
Well, it just depends on how much,
Like whatever, I don't wanna get graphic
but it depends on like things or whatever.
And I was like, girl,
if I get outta here and I
have tubes in this body,
we are gonna have a problem.
(all chuckle)
I was like, yeah.
- Exactly.
- Because I feel like some of us,
you could just like (blows)
and you get pregnant.
That's, that's, yeah.
Well, I didn't honestly think we could
and my fiance and I were talking about it.
I'm like, listen, I've
had multiple miscarriages
and I'm about to be 40.
So I'm, you know, I, I didn't know.
And the first month trying.
- Oh my god.
(guest chuckles)
It's powerful.
It can be powerful.
Do you have like a-
- Scottish power?
- (laughs) Yeah.
There ya go.
(audience laughs)
He's like, yes.
(audience claps)
So, are you feeling good?
Are you...
Your due date, is it soon?
- Four weeks.
- Oh my gosh.
(guest laughs)
- What are you doing here?
- Gosh! Exactly!
Do you know how to deliver a baby?
I was like.
- I was having contractions back there.
I was like, it's just
Braxton Hicks. We're fine.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Are you feeling okay?
- No girl, I'm ready.
Like, we're like.
(audience laughs)
- I was like that.
I was like,
Hey, baby, run's up, like it's time.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Get out!
- Yeah.
Aw. And you get-
- I think I'm-
- The skin on skin.
- Very blessed.
- My friend just had a
baby and I keep texting
about skin on skin time.
I love that time.
- That's the peace where I just wanna see
what he looks like and just hold on.
- Yeah.
- It's a beautiful thing
that we've created something
that I didn't think this would
be our, my story.
- What a beautiful surprise.
- Yeah.
- As well.